drei frösche herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe einige
vorbereitungen getroffen ihr seht ihr
bereits mit pizza ofen steht da feuer
magie steht das feuer
ich sag mal warum bewegt sich denn die
kamera ist auf einmal sebastian center
sebastian ich bin sebastian und ich
werde mich jetzt als erstes mit einer
pizza belohnt okay was redet kommt gibt
er war man spontanes pizza tutorial gibt
halte ich das sage dir ob du nie so eine
pizza gemacht anständig aber was ich
schon gemacht habe ist unseren heutigen
sponsor zu gratulieren dass er da ist
sie schon die workshops aus dem
englischen raum dann hat eben von den
kidnappern kleinen ganz kleiner channel
dann formen wir als erstes den rand wir
machen jetzt erstmal zu
demonstrationszwecken eine klassische
margarita können nassen stellen den sinn
da können wir auch schon hochnehmen
vornehmen sondern nach ein bisschen nach
vorn
die erste wird nie was ist einfach so
und dann können wir jetzt auch schon
meine tanten die zu belegen die wird
nämlich noch ein bisschen größer wenn
mir ergeht unfassbar fresh bei der luft
denn alter kennt ja das ist nicht
king of pop die die wird tatsächlich ein
bisschen größer wenn wir gleich auf den
schieber ziehen
mozzarella leute das ist jetzt aber nur
zu demonstrationszwecken wie gesagt weil
die pisten nicht gleich machen wenn
natürlich nichts mit pilzen zu tun haben
der schieber das ist immer das bisschen
schief gehen kann aber das ist so was
was man eigentlich so sehr schnell macht
macht man nicht so schnell aber man kann
dann auch einfach nach vorn so wie hier
jetzt bisschen chance nach link ist ja
sicher sehr guten das jetzt nicht eine
revolution
aber jetzt siehst du zum aller ersten
mal einen afrikanischen pizza gebacken
wird also ich gut rein
sein ton ist ja direkt und was ist jetzt
genommen plan für den rest des videos
der rucksack trägt wie immer der
rucksack der verbotenen dinge und wir
werden natürlich den pizzaofen
entfremden und pizza mit random sachen
machen
das ist es dann durch wenn das so
schnell geht das ist das einfach
anfangen kannst mit deinem gewandelt
er will eine nach pizza wirklich lange
wie lange läuft das video edge und wir
haben laufend 530 davon geredet 34
minuten einlud hier berät
dann schnappte man schön spießig der
boden nur verneigen ich kann nicht mal
das anpacken länger zweiten weil ich so
wenig haut an den fingern wird heiß sein
vorsicht
es ist schon echt eine perverse nummer
muss man sagen also wir machen es
einfach so gestellt den rucksack auf dem
tisch klar ich weiß schon was drin ist
aber medizin ohne hinzugucken
abwechselnd und ich wie viele kommen
denn auf eine pizza drei sachen drei
sachen drei tage haben wir noch ein
bisschen puffer und es ein bisschen
spannend wird einfach ich verspreche ich
werde direkt alles nämlich für
gasthäuser wegnehmen direkt machst
einfach du fängst hat aber gerne an
es wird sehr wertvoll so kann ich euch
sagen randall pizza berg etwas glück ja
ich musste das alles braucht man ja auch
alle nehmen ja es gibt die seite schon
hätte freddy tor komplett möhren ich
nehme das schon mal einzelne videos
musik wirklich kommt weiß ja wirklich
die café vorstellen
ich weiß natürlich was es ist
ich bin max und ich habe mal eine zeit
in italien gelebt aus diesem grund
flechsig gerne hier und damit meinen
italienischen schöne grüße an alle pizza
fisch bitten nachfolgend wegschalten
[Musik]
also konnten nicht das okay das könnte
mir auch ganz sicher ganz gut vorstellen
ich hoffe dass ich jetzt nichts süßes
bekommen weil ich habe nichts schmeckt
mit bachelor und süß gut
ja er müsse so 'ne ganze ecke pizza
werden das ist halt noch eine war jetzt
eine sache
er ist komplett immer gefühl oh nein oh
warte mal das passt perfekt zu der ferne
das passt sehr gut gegönnt und dann noch
ein paar mädchen drauf für die der
körper sich als sehr sogar
so auf l'osteria hälfte hälfte machen
[Musik]
italien einreise von coritiba sondern
das sind die momente wo man einfach und
steht hier mit dem kleinen ball war
keine freunde ich heute sagen wir welche
haben will ist wahrscheinlich
ich würde die kleine scheibe machen
konkret man waffeln ein musikkabarett
sein messer und ja ich schnell gemachte
pizza hälfte tomate schokolade
gerne gibt gerne ja und dann mache ich
auf die tomaten seite war ich meinem
einem märchen
denkst du wir kriegen jetzt so kann ich
ja schon ich habe schon keinen kalk am
okt
nochmal hier können darüber wie käse
natürlich mozzarella und so sind immer
drin kann man immer ein bisschen darauf
dass es so ein bisschen das über
schnittstelle vor die app finden jetzt
hier so eine neue pizza kreative ist
jedoch nach italienischen deutsche netto
deutsche metzger ich bin so gespannt auf
das was wird alter das ist so eine
bisher und hauptgerichte zwar in einigen
tälern und weißt du die leute die sagen
sogar schon das nachts muss und linken
könnte interessant werden würde sagen
letzte tram er auch wichtig weil sonst
die daran also wieder mit lucas erstmal
muss mit brille mal ein fußweg deutlich
schneller
so und jetzt hmm das einblenden
eine mutter oder ein vater bist du dein
glück versuchen und weinsheim okay das
mal wir müssen noch eine machen das mag
bei der letzten wahl findet ihr sie dann
als wie wenig sich auf die schokolade
verbrennen oder sollen wir erstmal die
ausstellung machen wir machen deine wir
machen meine patientin verurteilt wird
die gefühlt dein bier sind wir anders
wird jedoch eine kleine konsistenz
ich sage dir ganz genau was passieren
wollte max verliert in den ofen und wird
jeder damit auch hier oben eine million
prozent verbrennen und das wird dann
langsam nach unten brennen nächste und
letzte pizza
das war herzlich ein schrecklich
sie können jetzt noch einer vor und wir
folgen leute wir haben aus versehen ist
oder ob mir der ich meine dass 2021 ein
selbst wären meine ihr besser schmeckte
auch bei ok des konferenz ehrlich mit
den nüssen hin so ein bisschen an
prozent so wussten wahrscheinlich
schlecht nicht sagen es hat schon einen
guten die weißlichen wovor ich angst
habe dass der käse zu können verläuft
uns anfängt zu brennen
ich hoffe dass ihr nicht manchmal sogar
auch ich freue mich sobald die basler
ihr habt ja gerade schon gemerkt das
mikrofon wurde immer leiser und habe ein
bisschen herum gesponnen es ist dann
tatsächlich komplett leer gegangen aber
ihr seht her wir haben die pidas fertig
gemacht oder pizza wie man es auch
nennen mag was irgend einem grund war
das mikrofon an plötzlich wieder da
ich will einmal ganz mit der
messerspitze cookies gemacht
das ist voll gut gewesen und dann wieder
weg keine ahnung was da los war aber ja
sehen die schokolade war auf jeden fall
leicht verbrannt wir haben dann auch
probiert zuerst mal die pizza mit den
märchen wir waren beide echt überrascht
wurden irgendwie so karamellisiert und
richtig lecker dann habe ich aber auch
direkt schon quasi den bisher teil der
pizza probiert banane schokolade freddy
hatte kleine schwierigkeiten beim
abreißen aber es war wirklich
überraschend gut
dann war auch meine kreationen dran und
ich weiß so das sieht so aus als würde
jeder italiener mich dafür hassen aber
wir haben dann probiert und leute wir
waren beide echt überraschend sebastian
hat auch probiert freddy sagt in diesem
moment neun von zehn
ich weiß nicht wie viele glaubt noch
gesehen habt ja gefallen tun hat so
gesehen hat wie das der ton war weg
bisher ist man auch danke fürs zu sehen
leute schaut am sonntag vorbei
persönlicher koch einem sehr
interessanten
[Musik]